[Music]
to our first panel on green finance can
the city of london be the world's first
to deliver on climate change commitments
the way the city of london measures
success is constantly changing
a new generation of discerning customers
has skyrocketed the importance of
environmental
social and corporate governance to
company decision makers
the finance sector is increasingly being
seen as the next frontier in climate
action
as the city navigates the post-brexit
landscape and our pandemic recovery
it will also be tasked with redefining
its role on the world stage
so how will the government's net zero
commitment and the targets and the
targets in the paris agreement factor
into corporate decision making
how will banks and other financial
financial institutions change how they
weigh up sustainable investment choices
and what impact could all this have on
the broader economy
to join me to discuss all this and more
is ale jones head of sustainable
investment in europe for the ftse
russell
benedict mcgowan senior advisor and on
environment
and energy for policy exchange and kate
norgrove executive director of advocacy
and campaigns for wwf
and this panel is kindly sponsored by
wwf
if you are interested in putting
questions to our panel
you can submit those questions through
the text box on spectator tv
or you can email events at spectator dot
co dot uk
so we'll get a few opening remarks from
each of our panelists i'll ask a few
questions and then we'll go straight
to your questions benedict let's start
with you thank you very much kate and
thank you very much to
the spectator for hosting us today and
also to
wwf for sponsoring this very important
event and
and this very important summit um i'm
delighted to
come and talk to you about the financial
sector and its role
in achieving global net zero and really
it has an absolutely key role
in fact we cannot get to where we want
to go
without it and that's always been the
case with the financial sector and
and human society um wherever there's
been
massive progress in human society over
the last few centuries
financial sector has been incredibly
important um
when christopher columbus wanted to go
across oceans
the only people who could finance that
were were royalty
and yet nowadays or in fact just two
centuries after columbus
there was this thriving financial sector
which could fund trips around the world
all over the place so but they did that
by pooling resources by pooling risk
and and that's really this hugely
important role that the financial sector
has to play it enables society to do
what it wants to do
and nowadays society wants to get to net
zero we want to improve our impact
um on the planet and and actually turn
that into a positive impact rather than
the negative one that it is today so
so the financial sector is an enabler
and that's actually the first of
three areas that i think that the city
of london can can play an important role
so
those three areas are enablers as
accountants
and as regulators so firstly enablers
there is a huge number of products um
that
the city of london can sell to the world
that can enable
it to get to net zero so that might be
financing new technologies through
investment or underwriting it
it might be issuing green debt which
which supports new infrastructure
projects it
might be in researching opportunities
and using its expertise
in getting the most efficient allocation
of capital
uh so that that cost cuts the cost of um
of the net zero transition
um banks like natwest and tsb are
issuing mortgages
that are linked to homeowners investment
in energy efficiency for example
so there's all these opportunities that
you can sell to the world as an enabler
through the products that you sell
and secondly accountants the
it's been said in the past that um
accountants will save the world and i
absolutely believe that because
there's a real problem in esg data that
it's pretty
fuzzy and there's lots of overlapping
and uh
and and double accounting and we need to
solve that through much more efficient
accountancy
methods and and the city of london sits
as a global financial hub and it has
this huge opportunity
to set the standards um the
the financial world is sort of
coalescing around certain things
uh certain standards and frameworks but
it's it's taking a little bit of a time
to get there and and we need that to
to improve and i'm i'm sure um allied
will speak about that in a moment
um the third area and that sort of
neatly leads us on to the third area of
regulators
um in terms of setting standards the uk
has this massive role
as i say it's a financial hub it has
this
huge role in influencing how business is
done
and i think it was the the head of ubs
said we can't just add a few more
galaxies to this universe we need a
whole new universe we need to reset the
standards for how
everything works um so it was fantastic
to see
tcfd being adopted by the g7 recently
that's a framework for
for disclosing risks in the financial
sector related to climate change
um we called for that at policy exchange
earlier this year with a a report that i
co-authored
brilliant to see the g7 adopting that
there's a couple of
problems with that though or rather
limits to it and
those are that it's focused on risks
and material impacts in the financial
sector we need to see
transition plans that that companies
adopt to show how they're moving to net
zero
um we need to see things like a task
force for nature
related financial disclosures and we
need to see things like
capital charges which are rules for for
banks
stability um they need to start
recognizing the inherent risks in
fossil fuel investments um there's a
there's a huge range of other things
that regulators can do but the uk has
this massive role
and it's already shown with the g7 that
it can take a leader's leadership
position
um so i want to see more of more of that
sort of thing
i think a bigger thing that the city of
london has to offer
um to the world is it's it's it's um
heritage of um
uh principles-based regulation which is
really effective
in terms of allowing a culture of
innovation within a sort of um
within a broader based set of
regulations that encourage green
innovation so um
the city of london has this massive and
central role to play
as an enabler as accountants and as
regulators
and i think that it's an essential and
indispensable role that i'm
looking forward to seeing develop over
the coming years
thank you so much benedict aled
thanks kate and i okay benedict's
comment sir thanks spectator and wwf
for making this happen and to everyone
who's um signed in first thing on a
monday morning to talk about climate
change among
amongst other jolly subjects um i'll
perhaps
yeah there's three three broad comments
i just wanted to make to
set the scene and then um i'll pass over
to kate so
from my perspective um so i work within
the index business of ftse russell which
is part of the london stock exchange
group so i spend most of my time
speaking to large investors asset owners
in particular like pension schemes
you know large pools of money that are
looking to
put money against kind of index based
products or
use benchmarks to understand the markets
they're tracking essentially across
their investment strategy so
um three things that i can see emerging
for discussions that i have
across these european universities
european investor base one
climate as you might not be surprised
even what we talk about here is it's
never been higher on the investors
agenda i mean
and it's happened very very quickly
actually to get to the point where we
are today talking about net zero
compared to
three four years ago when everyone was
just talking about carbon emissions and
low carbon approaches
it's it's really skyrockets up the
agenda i mean there's assets flowing
into funds there's all sorts of
commitments coming out
i think kate mentioned that beginning
her remarks about net zero commitments
um the support for quite progressive
agendas through um
groups like the igcc the institutional
investors group on climate change
the transition pathway initiative co 100
plus all things i can happily get into
later
um it's really it's really certainly in
europe at least it's really top of the
investor's agenda
and i don't see that changing secondly
the debate as i alluded to earlier has
become much more sophisticated
um in a very short space of time
compared to say just three to five years
ago so
as i mentioned uh three five years ago
people were just talking about carbon
emissions how can we lower the carbon
intensity of our portfolios now it's
about
how do i get to net zero which is a
completely different
thing i mean it still encompasses those
same same issues and carbon
is definitely a big part of that but
it's it's you know it's a level of
complexity that didn't exist
not that long ago um
that is tricky in many ways for the
average investor to say like a pension
scheme trustee because there's no right
way of doing this
benedict alluded to the fact that um
within the world of esg
um there is there's very few if any
standards which can be a challenge so
there's you know there's no right way of
getting to net zero there's no right way
of assessing your portfolio for esg risk
there's no right way of
assessing a company based on esg metrics
and again happy to get into that so it
is
it's great to see the debate becoming
much more sophisticated i do think from
an implementation perspective for the
average investor
it's quite it can be quite tricky um and
the last one
last point i'll make for now is um i
think certainly from the perspective i
come at this
so you know index based investment for
the most part
it's as much as if not more about risk
than it is about returns
um in the sense that you know i i see
most
investors that i work with looking to
essentially take a very large broad
market portfolio that invests in
thousands of stocks through which
they're trying to
earn like the market return on market
beta um
they're trying to shift these portfolios
progressively towards say lower carbon
companies or maybe slightly greener
companies or quote unquote more
responsible companies
um which is about managing risk at the
same time as generating or receiving at
least the same kind of returns or risk
adjusted returns you might get in a
standard what we call market cap
portfolio
now there's lots of interesting
opportunities especially around the
green
part of the economy but from a broad
broad market investor perspective i
you know most of the discussions i see
this is really about managing risk and
when it comes to climate there's plenty
of risk to be managed
so i'll i'll leave it there thank you so
much
and over to you kate thanks kate um and
i want to thank the spectator and
uh our guest for taking the time today
to talk about what is possibly the
biggest opportunity for the uk
uh because although obviously um it's
about risk it's also about
uh returns um and uh
you know mark carney and others have
talked about just how much of an
opportunity there is in this sector
um we need to mobilize our world-class
finance sector
um and transition that investment flow
to accelerate the whole economy to a 1.5
degree pathway
and doing that that will support the
industries of the future and make the uk
the world centre for green finance
so you might be asking yourself why a
wwf an organization that's known mainly
for conserving megafauna
deciding to partner with some of the big
beasts in finance
and that's quite simply because the
challenges that we face are now so large
that saving just one species misses the
point
we must fix the systemic issues that are
driving climate change and the loss of
biodiversity
not only for those species sake but also
for the human species sake because this
is now an issue that threatens
all of us our planet is no longer in the
safe operating space
upon which our civilizations have been
made
as an organization we strongly believe
that our work needs to be grounded in
good science
um and you'd expect that whether that's
advising on camera trapping for lions in
the
serengeti or supporting hsbc's
science-based net-zero targets
and the science tells us that we can't
keep using our planet's resources
or emitting carbon dioxide at the
current rate
and you'll have seen this already storms
wildfires
the rain this weekend floods extreme
temperatures and other climate-related
national
natural disasters are more frequent and
more violent and they're more likely to
be caused by
by climate uh they're destroying our
homes our pending lives and costing
billions of pounds each year
and the global economy cannot carry on
as if it's business as usual
in fact this pandemic the covid crisis
is linked to
uh biodiversity loss because humans and
animals are getting much much closer
together because
of deforestation so it's a it's a
massive risk
to the whole economy um the uk's finance
sector punches above its weight in many
ways
uh but that also includes in its carbon
emissions so our recent report
uh wwf and greenpeace the big smoke
showed that
financed emissions from a subset of just
25 uk banks
and asset managers were equivalent to
1.8 times the net
emissions of the uk so at a very very
conservative estimate that says that the
uk's finance sector is supporting
emissions that
where it were a country would see it
ranked ninth in the world so more than
canada and only slightly less than
germany which is
pretty extraordinary really so are the
finance dimensions of uh the city of
london is going in the opposite
direction
still financing fossil fuels um to the
extent that it is
um uh to the uk itself which is starting
to
to pull out of all of those so reversing
this trend is a massive challenge but
it's also a big opportunity
um it's a really exciting time as as we
were just saying just before
this all started there are so many
financial sector organizations now
talking about
uh net zero the private sector has
always been at the forefront
of innovation to solve problems we now
have the chance to ensure that the
finance sector leads the world to a
cleaner more sustainable and stable
future
let's seize that opportunity and let's
do it in the year that the eyes of the
world are on the uk
because given the international nature
of the finance sector changes in the uk
would send shock waves globally
so credit where credit is due the fact
that we're here today
shows that the dial has started to be
shifted
and greening finance is firmly on the
agenda the uk government have fired the
starting gun
and rightly recognized that this isn't
just about corporate responsibility and
the sideline in csr this is a uk
leadership opportunity
mandatory climate disclosure so the tcfd
thing that
benedict just talked about is a
fundamental first step
this does allow us to see where the risk
is and what needs to change
but it's only really the calories on the
pack it just tells us what we're
emitting now
it doesn't tell us what the plan is uh
to to get to it and that makes it a very
slow nudge game
and time is not a luxury that we have so
we must realign our financial system so
that it drives the outcomes
consistent with the paris agreement and
the achievement of 1.5 degrees
so that investment flows faster towards
a low carbon economy
we must do this in the time frames
outlined by the science and for that we
really really don't have long
and there's a massive role for the uk
government as presidents of cot 26 to
lead the global agenda on this
leveling up laggard so that our
world-class financial system
is supporting our climate and ambitions
not undermining them
so that's why we want the uk to commit
to being the first in the world to align
our finance system with the paris goals
and net zero targets
and i'm really looking forward to this
discussion on how we can move forward on
the journey
to achieving this well thank you so much
kate and we already have
questions coming in which is fantastic
i'm going to abuse my position as chair
and
ask a few myself before we get to them
and just a reminder to all of our
watchers at home
anybody can submit a question use the
text box on spectator tv
or you can email events at spectator dot
co dot uk
um you know i just want to pick up on on
some of the you know
really big statements that have been
made in these opening remarks i mean
kate
you say that if we look at the emissions
that the city is financing it's
equivalent to the ninth
largest or tenth largest polluting
country in the world i mean where to
begin
on that how does the city go about
navigating the trade-offs of
where it feels it has to continue to
invest where the money is and
how it makes this huge switch to
supporting more green
and clean uh industries and and sectors
and initiatives
yeah i mean it's it's unbelievable um so
you know it's one of those things where
we have to
start to have the policy to enable this
this shift to happen quicker
um and as benedict was saying we need to
realign the finance sector
with our net zero goals and with the
goals of the paris
agreement so uh it's a it's a good a
really good first step to have had tcfd
which is the
the um the the format i guess that
allows you
or enables you makes it mandatory to
disclose your climate risks
but that's nowhere near enough it sort
of measures the temperature without
we're at
now rather than turning down the heat so
what we need is the government to say
look by the end of 2022
so what we want is by cop 26 the
government to have said by the end of 22
we expect finance sector to publish
their plans to reach 1.5 degrees
um to align with the paris agreement and
that will give
financial sector sort of 18 months ish
to do the work
to publish that plan um because
otherwise we're in the situation where
they've said you know these terrible
things are going to happen but they've
not
um you know and this this is a massive
risk to our business but they don't have
to do anything about it
um and some of the world's leading
organizations uh like aviva for example
have already published their plans it's
totally possible to do
and that's what we expect others to do
as well benedict it may be possible to
do but it's still a huge challenge are
you hopeful that in the next year and a
half such a plan will be delivered
i'm i'm uh i'm an eternal optimist kate
i i think uh you have to be in in this
game but um
look there's definitely going to be
challenges along the way but we are
seeing
a big change at the moment and and this
is a crucial year as kate said you know
we've got cop 26 at the end of the year
but we've also got
um and especially the uk has a key role
in these these things
and we've got a new um administration in
the white house who
which has made um climate change it's
it's abs you know one of its top three
uh goals um we've got
a number of diplomatic summits which are
crucial so cop 26 is obviously
incredibly important we've got the g20
which traditionally has a sort of
financial focus
and that's being hosted by italy which
is also
closely we're partnering with italy on
on cop26 so that has a sort of
a focus on on this stuff as well we've
just had the g7
didn't have a huge amount of progress if
we're honest about um climate change but
it's certainly
set a a sort of tone and an agenda in in
in the right direction and we've also
got things that are slightly
less high profile but things like you
know that we've got the
commonwealth heads of government meeting
later this year and when i was talking
about
principles-based regulation that's a
fantastic place
in which to to advance some of these
agendas
um can we do it in the time available i
think
yes we can but we do need to get a move
on and i would absolutely echo
kate's point that each individual
company has to come up with a transition
plan
when we talk about tcfd which is a big
you know headline banner thing
that's about risk we need to talk about
actual
actions that are moving companies in the
right direction
um in line with the paris agreements 1.5
target and and you know that's down to
companies themselves but it's also up to
investors and uh and those investors
um are taking a you know an active uh
stance on this
i would encourage your your viewers to
look up the say on climate campaign i
think that's very important
um there's obviously a lot more to be
done by governments
and we can come on to that later and
love to talk about that in a moment
and speaking of those investors aled
where do they begin
when it comes to making this monumental
shift because they have so many
competing priorities and you know
they're they're they're looking at
profits uh they're looking at what they
think is going to be successful in the
short term but then of course making
this
huge shift over the next few decades i
mean
is there a practical step-by-step
handbook to this or are we in completely
new uncharted territory i wish there was
a handbook um
i mean there's i mean we're certainly
not in uncharted territory i mean this
is an
area that i've at least many other
people have worked in for
for many years but it and it's good to
see that the spotlight really shining on
these issues finally in the in yeah in
the last say two three years in
particular
i think you know there's it is
challenging because to say there's
there's a lot to get your head around as
an investor because these aren't kind of
typical the climate transition is not
kind of typical
investment strategy kind of thing that
you you capture and in these discussions
the information can be patchy um but
there's a lot there's a lot of positive
signs so
one example is the transition pathway
initiative to tpi they
you know they since 2017 have been
trying to you know support
investor efforts here by assessing
companies in a fairly
uh intuitive and very transparent way to
give investors
the information they need to start
making decisions whether it's about
companies to engage within their
portfolios companies to
maybe um invest more or less in based on
their performance on different
um characteristics or maybe even
completely avoid so what you know
in particular they look at for example
to what extent have companies committed
to reduce their
their operational emissions in line with
what we know is needed to hit these
paris goals they look at
say the 400 500 biggest and most carbon
intensive businesses globally
and then they assess them in different
you know and put into different buckets
so
based on their latest uh transition um
summary report
only about 15 of those 400 companies
they were looking at
last year say have got any kind of plans
to hit these one and a half degree
um warming targets so that's quite a
small number when you think about it
even though these are very large
companies and actually if you look at
say a
listed equity universe that group of
companies while small
does account for you know upwards of
fifty percent of the carbon intensity of
that particular universe
so yeah but this information is the
starting point they're they're
essentially trying to say
that we're all investors we want this to
work we don't want to have to ideally
divest from these companies let's work
with them let's help them understand
the importance of this transition and
what investors need to know very much
linked to the tcfd which is the sort of
disclosure framework that kate mentioned
but i agree it is very much that's just
very much the starting point yeah we
need this information so we can make
know informed decisions about where to
allocate our capital over the long term
so so the tpis is one part of that
process they're linked to other
initiatives on the c100 plus which is
a very very engagement focused program
and that's again looking at these large
carbon intensive companies and again the
the outcome really is kind of at this
stage around
disclosure and commitments you know like
pushing companies to make
clear and public commitments to reduce
their emissions in particular
um out you know 20 30 20 50 so we can at
least as investors start to understand
which companies might be winners and
losers because
the bottom line is that you know we want
these energy automotive
airline utility companies to make this
transition but the bottom line is they
won't wall make it because it might be
possible or maybe they're dragging their
feet but
this is i say it is tricky because
there's a huge amount of urgency here
but we are in quite early days in terms
of broad you know the broad
group of investors actually getting
their head around what they can do and
how and why
but things are the encouraging side is
things are like i said earlier
moving very very quickly i mean it's
astonishing how much
attention is now being placed on this
issue in kind of investment circles so
that that for me is the
the optimistic point here well clarity
is
key and benedict you mentioned in
esgs and and that oftentimes it just
actually
the data around it wasn't very clear i
mean investing
in esg is does seem to be all the rage
these days but
can we know do we have the data to know
whether or not it's actually making a
difference yet
i think um we
it's a good question as to what exactly
is making the difference
um i think that there is a ultimately i
i'm not sure that the market
necessarily is in the driving seat at
the moment um
it is responding to major trends in
you know in in regulatory change and
policy change around the world
but we are seeing um certain asset
classes becoming increasingly
uneconomic there's a lot of doubt around
uh you know investment in coal for
example even though we hear lots of
horror stories about you know further
investment in coal but a lot of that
investment is backed up by
um effectively sovereign wealth funds
especially in the chinese uh
road initiatives so we're seeing asset
classes that are
shifting out um and and that's a
out of you know their sort of acceptable
market investment portfolio because
um that's a response to regulation and
also a response to
public perceptions you know we talk a
lot about um transition risks
including the way that consumers
view products and services
if if you see a company that is
investing in coal
that makes you less likely to buy its
products because
you don't want to engage with that so in
some ways we're seeing asset classes
moving out of the of the mainstream
market
and you're certainly seeing an awful lot
moving in so we're seeing a massive
uptick
in the value of green technologies
and i think that that is a combination
of regulations moving in the right
direction lots of noise around that um
at this global level
politically and then secondly um
market investors recognizing there's
there's
there's something to be had here um so
we saw the
um creation of around 500 esg funds last
year
and i think that is um part of a pretty
much a mega trend
and that is going to have a difference
but it needs a lot awful lot more
structure and
awful lot more data um to support it
kate what do you think do we have enough
data and evidence at our fingertips to
assess the changes being made in the
city
we need we certainly need a lot more
like alert and benedict have
referred to this is not simple it's uh
it's complex and the transition out of
dirty industries to to cleaner ones
when it comes to climate is difficult
but when you add in nature
as well it becomes even more difficult
so how do you measure
um moving out of um deforestation in
your supply chains for example
um and that's where something like tnfd
which benedict was
referring to in the in their report as
well is is so important
um uh and we've seen in terms of esg
we've seen a significant rise as others
have said in the uptake and importance
placed on esg investing
um this is of course welcome um but
uh it doesn't necessarily result in the
big changes we need in the real world
um and so we need to go beyond the sort
of basics
of uh esg data metrics climate risk
disclosure and more towards the
portfolio alignment with 1.5 degrees and
net zero um
i wanted to just mention that i think
alongside this that having the
government policies that
help support the transitional make clear
to the finance sector where the
transition needs to happen
are so important so when benedict was
talking about asset classes in relation
to
fossil fuels and green technology the
other area we need to look at although
it's less well-known is is agriculture
and so what are the policy what are the
uk government policies on on agriculture
going to be um and and can we use those
in the finance sector to help drive the
finance sector to the right type of
uh investment in in agriculture for the
future
um and one last point is that
politically this is such an amazing
opportunity for the uk government to
um to put their weight behind a 1.5
degree
degrees under a paris aligned financial
sector in the uk
it's just a no-brainer i think um we
could be the first financial sector
to to make that announcement to a linear
to align the city of london
and it's just a big opportunity for the
uk and for the city of london
and that we shouldn't miss the idea of
taking up um it's a it's a great
contribution to global britain as um
boris johnson would say we've had a
question through about the possibility
of a green
bubble as people rush for esg
there's phenomenal interest in tesla but
some are already critical
about its valuation and in the valuation
of electric vehicles more generally
aled with your investor cap on are you
at all worried about a green bubble that
may be set to burst
personally no then it's not necessarily
my specific area of expertise but i mean
tesla is a good example because
um the phenomena you know what is
achieved is phenomenal the attention it
achieves is incredible always has a very
charismatic slightly bonkers um chief
executive who's really gonna
keep you staying in the spotlight um i
mean i
i guess you know there is to make a
point there is
there's a lot more capital shifting into
whether you know esg funds or go across
across the spectrum of passive and
active deep green thematic very broad sg
integrated
um yeah in the tens if not hundreds of
billions of dollars flowing into these
kind of um approaches but you know
a lot of the time it's not it's not just
green funds there's
a there's a huge range of different uh
phones and products out there as i
mentioned earlier
what i do with day to day is mostly
about taking what you think of as a very
standard portfolio and essentially sort
of
nudging it to use case uh coming earlier
towards companies that perhaps a bit
better than others so it's
it's actually in terms of the capital
shift currently it's it's not
it's not significant enough in my mind
to create huge bubbles in companies that
seem as being more responsible for
having better esg practices or being low
carbon now
um the tester point is particularly
interesting
for me as a bit of a kind of esg nerd in
that
when you look at large global equity
universes you know you look at
the top 10 holdings the biggest 10
companies in these
these universes companies like exxon
have forever been in that top 10 is a
very very large global oil and gas
company
uh in the last you know few months not
least because of what's been happening
in the wider economy
um exxon's disappeared from the top 10
and tesla's now in it and that that's a
big shift now
whether that's a bubble or whether
that's the the first signs of
an actual transition away from say
fossil fuel sector towards say greener
sectors
is yet to be seen i think it's too early
to say but it is it's a very interesting
question you know
but also tesla is fascinating because if
you look at just his products
it's extremely green in the sense it's
trying to encourage us to have electric
vehicles solar panels
batteries etc um but if you look at it
from a broad esg perspective which is
more about understanding
how operations well you know the
operational side of things like you know
disclosure levels corporate governance
how i treat its workforce et cetera et
cetera
it tends to do extremely poorly so and
that and that's a great you know and for
me fascinating interesting
contradictions sometimes within esg is
like you're having to balance these
decisions sometimes between
do i go full green and just kind of
focus on that or do i
factor in some of these broader things
which are also extremely important
around
you know labor relations etc diversity
etc etc now and then
so tesla sits right at the middle of
that kind of
um discussion so i think yeah but
there's there's many other examples you
could look at it's yeah it is
yeah esg
like the world around us is very much
about there's no black and white it's
very much about grey areas and i think
in terms of today um tesla actually is
is a great company because of what it's
producing and it's also made some very
strong commitments around
the climate transition so the tpi
analysis i mentioned earlier
has tesla very much aligned with 2
degree or below 2 degree in terms of its
operational carbon emissions so
from that sense i think it's to be
applauded but it could definitely do a
lot better in terms of broader
disclosures most operational practices
benedict we've had a question through
from alan who asked whether or not
renewables can comprehensively
replace fossil fuels i suppose it ties
into the green bubble point i mean
either
this is going to become a new way of
life in which we're not talking about
bubbles we're talking about you know the
way that we
um use and consume energy uh or it's not
uh where do you fall down on on on this
do you do you think they can
comprehensively make the shift
um i think it's very important point and
in some ways it relates to the previous
question you know
so the previous question i would i would
say you know there's a
there's two different types of bubble
there's the sort of tulip mania that was
was seen in the netherlands a few
hundred years ago which was about
fashion it was a sort of flash in the
pan
and so when it burst um that that was
you know that didn't change anything
structurally in the in the global
economy whereas
um what we're talking about here is that
the real fundamentals you know energy
sits at the absolute
base of um of the global economy
um and so i don't think that in the long
term it's
uh it's it's a bubble and uh you know
there might be a bit of frothiness
around certain companies in the in the
short term
but if you're a long-term investor
looking at green investments then it's a
fantastic thing to be
looking at and and to answer the the
question about
can renewables uh replace um uh
fossil fuels in the global energy system
yes absolutely they can
um there are questions around you know
things like
intermittent um uh sources of energy
that dependent on the weather so wind
and solar and that sort of thing but
those are the sort of questions of
you know maybe 10 years ago and and
those companies sorry those countries
that are ahead on on decarbonizing their
power sectors such as the uk
are showing that you can absolutely
manage through a combination of things
like
demand demand side response uh batteries
um and dispatchable energy sources
like hydro or bioenergy or things like
that
you can you can you can balance out
those sort of peaks and troughs in the
energy system that
you are going to get um but it can
absolutely be done and there's
there's no question in my mind that
renewables
can completely replace fossil fuels
and kate we've also had a question
through about corporate governance
um one of our watchers has said that
they've heard reports of executives
having their bonuses
tied to meeting sustainability targets
should we expect to see
more of that i mean at the end of the
day leadership does come from the top
and
it seems like a fairly important point
to be talking about when we talk about
the city of london what what the chief
execs are actually up to
that's uh that's bang on and i think the
most progressive companies have got
climate and nature as part of the
responsibilities
of various board directors um so
uh you know look at tesco's for the
moment for example they
um uh you know like all retailers they
work on the basis of quite short term
um in terms of thinking about their
risks their risks are about you know
yeah is there going to be disruption in
their supply chain next week
let alone thinking about the long-term
risks um you know three ten years out
from from climate and the destruction of
nature
um but they've now got a board member at
the most senior level responsible
for climate and nature risks which means
they are having now and
uh proactively dealing with the risks
that are for their business over the
next sort of
um uh you know 10 15
20 years um there's a question just
going back to the
to the bubble question if if i may um
around
uh whether the the carbon bubble is
actually the one to be more worried
about
because uh given the majority of the of
the
uh of the economy is now dependent on
fossil fuel and based energy production
and we know carbon uses is limited by
science i'd be much more worried about
that
uh than i would be about anything else
and just on the renewables question as
well
um like i said i think the next i mean
there's there's big focus on
on the energy transition quite rightly
but in some ways that transition is
happening it's on its way
um whereas 25 percent quarter of the of
the world's
carbon emissions are produced by
agriculture
and are the way we use our land that's
the next big area to look at in terms of
of the transition both from an
opportunity and a risk perspective
and so both governments uh governments
should be regulating uh on this as we
are in a way
as we sort of got out of the common
agricultural policy
um but they uh but finance sectors
should also be looking at this as well
and it's not just boards holding their
ceos to account in the way that they're
leading their companies is it
alid shareholders have a lot of sway
and control over holding companies to
account as well for their climate impact
do you think we are really seeing the
difference that a shareholder's decision
as to whether or not they want to invest
in a company is making
i mean i think the point around
shareholder engagement is a really
important one i think this is there's
always been
a lot of engagement with companies over
the last decade or more by
you know by leading investors whether
it's investors like aviva that kate
mentioned earlier or you know groups of
asset owners
things like the igcc or the umpri that i
mentioned i think it's starting to
really become
especially around climate it's starting
to have a lot of success i think the
the approaches and the asks of companies
become more sophisticated more perhaps
you could say investor aligned
and i guess capturing the current
level of debate i guess around climate
or just being more successful i mean
you've seen
the last month exxon engagement with
exxon which has historically been very
difficult
um having you know huge successes in
terms of getting
uh perhaps you could say more
open-minded board members onto that
company board and there's there's other
examples in recent years through uh
initiatives like aiming for a under the
cdp so
there's some you know the ca100 plus
i've already mentioned is
is definitely being successful in terms
of pushing for
much better information and commitments
around uh paris
um so i think yeah i think there's yeah
that there's a lot a long way still to
go with that especially within
in the passive investment context as
well people have historically thought
well if you invest passively you can't
really effectively engage but i would
disagree with that i think as
as a passive investor especially as an
asset manager say where you're investing
in essentially the entire economy i
think it's incumbent upon you to engage
with companies even if
you can't necessarily sell them because
you have to hold the market but
you're you're essentially a perpetual
owner of these businesses and
you know you or your your clients assets
at least if they're facing
risks under climate change and it's
absolutely you know
required that you engage with these
companies pretty vigorously
we're starting to see that a lot more um
one last
one like one quick additional reference
to the green economy uh point we were
talking about earlier is just
said there's um it's quite
quite often when people think about the
green card they just think when you have
learning cheat right
it's so much more than that i mean if
you look at so we have
firstly track the green economy through
a green revenue data set that we have
and we
we we you know put out reports you know
every couple of years we tried to
on the state of things and if you if you
break down the green economy as we look
at it
um at least half of the global clean
economy is actually taken up by things
like energy efficiency
uh increasingly you know technology
companies transportation and it
obviously
renewable energy both the companies that
make equipment to
support renewable energy but also
utility companies that generate green
energy
is a huge part of what we're talking
about but it it's just so much more than
that and the opportunities across
the global kind of landscape are just
getting
bigger and bigger if you if you don't
just look at say what you might call a
pure play green company
maybe only make solar panels or a
particular widget that goes into a green
product and you look at companies that
are active in many different green
sectors
um like i said like waste or energy
efficiency et cetera et cetera you've
got
you know globally an opportunity that's
in the trillions around four trillion
dollars or something you've estimated
and it's
it's actually now at least the same size
if not bigger than the global oil and
gas sector so yeah and we're seeing
those sectors you know
green is growing and oil and gas is
shrinking at least in terms of market
value so again
these could be promising signs of a
transition that is underway and picking
up steam
kate what role do regulators have to
play in this i'm thinking for example
of the bank of england saying it might
penalize banks facilitating heavy
polluters
yeah certainly and and there are already
news i mean the bank of england has just
taken on
um as you said this new uh requirement
that they
look at um uh transition plans
and um and make judgments according to
those i think
uh without regulation we're not gonna do
this um
it's not happening fast enough at the
moment and um
the one thing as i've said that we'd
like to see before cop 26
is the government commit to asking
financial sector um the financial sector
to
publish their plans to meet 1.5 degrees
in the way that they invest
so we're not going to do it without uh
regulation it's not going to happen fast
enough
um so and i just wanted to come back if
i can to the public
action point or the sort of stakeholder
um action point there's there's 2.6
trillion
in uh in uk's pensions and that money is
essentially owned
by the public and is expected to build
our investments for the future
um but that's a really good way of
individuals taking action
from because from fossil fuels tobacco
exploitation to extraction
um pension our money is invested in
things that may not align with our
values so
richard curtis has got this campaign
called make my money mata
which is about getting uh people to to
shift their money to pensions with
values that they agree with
and we would certainly support that um
there's uh there's a um a really good an
important role for
financial um in the for the financial
sector to also be working with
regulators
uh to um to make sure that that
regulation
uh works for them and that there's uh
that the regulators
have some role in accountability and
enforcement of the of the
policies that uh are mandated for them
benedict regulations are necessary
in in in in some um sectors and and
in plenty of areas in order to keep
everybody
you know at a fundamental level of
safety but they do of course have
unintended consequences a lot of the
time and we've seen that
especially in the green sector seeing as
there's so much demand for esg
friendly investments is the solution
more regulations stricter regulation or
perhaps that we just need stronger
signposting
i think um there's a difference between
the types of regulation
um that and the different approaches
that we're seeing around the world so
in the uk we we have you know the common
law system
which has lent itself over the years to
to principles rate based regulation
um the eu on the other hand is the
standard bearer for
for a more sort of civil law approach
which it inherits
really from from france and um and
that's led to rules-based regulation
and in my view rules-based regulation
leads to effectively
box-ticking culture that can't really
keep up with
changes in technology and uh and and
the real world out there whereas
principles based
is much more sort of broad and it says
you know here are the outcomes that
we're looking
for here are the types of behaviors that
we're looking for
and that allows you firstly a slightly
lower regulatory burden on these
companies
also allows more sort of
opportunity to to uh to innovate and and
to come up with your own solutions
rather than just ticking the box of uh
what the regulators are looking for and
it also encompasses all sort of
um situations um rather than just the
ones that the regulators were thinking
about in advance
which means that you can sort of um try
and
prevent gaming of the system um and and
those who are sort of
trying regulatory arbitrage and that
sort of thing um
so there are definitely ways you can
design this regulation in in a way that
is
hopefully lighter touch but ultimately
you know
the best ways of doing this are things
like a market-based solutions things
like
setting a a global carbon
price or at least one that you can you
can implement
in local scenarios that that reflects a
sort of internationally
uh respected standard you know we need
these sort of international agreements
so that so that we're all on the same
page on this
ali do you think that a a global carbon
price would aft
actually give investors some sense of
relief
even if it meant that in some areas
prices were
going up uh taxes were going up at least
there would be
certainty as to how we're going to
handle uh this question of combating
climate change
i mean certainly you know exactly what
the answer is i i don't know
to be honest there is we clearly need a
means
of uh investors and companies actually
being able to
price some of this risk and reflect you
know have it reflected in
market prices um whether it's a carbon
price or some sort of taxation
actually do that to the policy experts
but yeah there is
i guess the the reason we're here today
is because
the market so far has failed to kind of
effectively price this risk we're
talking about was your climate so
yeah and the measures the activities
underway and these kind of discussions
are definitely helping and there's you
know there's
many measures thankfully happening
including in the uk you know requiring
us owners for example to now report
against the tcft etc now
yeah it could be the stronger measures
are required obviously
agreeing on global carbon prices imagine
incredibly complex
um and even even the balance between has
been it was saying you know
kind of rules based on principle-based
regulations a tricky one yeah i think i
agree that
rules based is can be overly
prescriptive and we're seeing that in
some areas currently
from some of the rules coming out of the
eu but equally principles based one
could argue you might be too slow to
see kind of real concrete change
depending on how that's backed up so
i think there's gonna yeah we need a
kind of a package of measures here and
actually
you know investors in particular really
holding
companies to account and you could argue
also that the end client really should
be holding their
investment intermediaries to account as
well here there's a long
there's a long chain of stakeholders
that need to be connected up um to make
all this stuff work
um but yeah i mean to your specific
point we
some measure of pricing this risk more
effectively and systematically would be
extremely helpful
and kate this brings us to cop26 these
are the difficult conversations that
world leaders are going to have to be
having and they're going to have to find
some areas of cooperation if they are
um to tackle this at at the global
level is there a risk though that we
come out of cop26 with
more pledges more lofty promises that we
haven't actually gotten into the
the gritty politics and policy like
we've been discussing today
yeah i mean there's always that risk um
and uh cop 26 it's not going to be like
paris in
sort of a big moment where everyone
agrees on amount because this is about
ratcheting up
individual countries commitments and i
think there's a risk of
expectations that we say okay well cop
26 is going to be the big moment where
everything happens
and it may not be like that um but i'm
pretty sure that there's going to be
some
decent progress um and and i think in
the uk at least that will be driven
by domestic action and policy certainty
in domestic action so
one of the things we're looking for in
the autumn is the publication of the
the government's long-term uh strategy
to reach net zero
and we hope that that's going to cover a
bunch of sectors and
uh talking about regulation um that they
will announce a net zero test on all of
government spending uh so that uh
there's some
policy certainty that uh the the actual
you know the
core spending is spent in consistent
ways with the
net zero target um so if we can see that
then i think we'll be in a much better
position to ask for the financial sector
to do the same thing
and ask for other governments to do the
same thing as well and i think
there's lots of hope in uh in the biden
administration
um in uh targets uh been announced by
china in recent months uh to reach net
zero at least by 2060
and to start phasing out of coal
by 2030 so it's obviously not fast
enough
but it is moving in the right direction
um
but you know overall for us uh success
will look like 1.5 degrees being still
on the table and still
feasible by the end of court 26 and so
that's what we'll be
looking for um benedict we've had a
question through
asking whether or not the city really
does want to achieve
net zero and get to that target or
whether or not the commentary
wants the city to want to achieve net
zero
and it's it's fair pushback isn't it you
could look to
to plenty of business in the city of
london and say well your practices or
what you're still investing in really
doesn't look like net zero is that the
heart
of your agenda in your conversations
with business how serious do you think
they're
how seriously do you think they're
taking this target i think
um you're obviously going to find a huge
range of people who are
just out to make money um and let's be
honest that's
what the city has been being built
around
um but also you get a huge number of
people who are genuinely committed they
want to
use the position that they have in the
world to to influence this agenda and
support it
um so so i you know i think that there
is a
range um we do
hear from leading investors um large
investor groups the types that allad has
been speaking about
that they are that this is absolutely
core to their agenda and they're going
to press
um the companies that they're invested
in um to ensure this
i think that's that's the sort of you
know the kind of the moral position
but there's also the the hard-nosed um
material
point that climate change is going to
cause damage to portfolios to
loan books to underwritten um assets
um around the world and and that goes to
the bottom line
so when we talk about you know
implementing tcfd all we're talking
about is
is um identifying the financial risks
that underlie assets and i'm talking
about assets
all around the world in almost every
single asset class
um and those assets are becoming
stranded either totally or partially by
climate change either by the physical
reality of climate change or by the
policies that are being
implemented so that goes to the bottom
line
so if you're an investor and you're not
thinking about how this
massive global mega trend this
phenomenon
that has never happened before in human
uh society
um if you're not thinking about how
that's impacting
your investments then you're really in
the wrong job
so uh i think there are there is a huge
awareness of that and it's a growing
awareness
um and and it's not just pr it's not
just froth it's a recognition that this
goes to the business case of the city of
london
um so so i'm optimistic that it's being
accepted in increasing
uh seriousness alan do you think that
business case has helped to sway hearts
and minds the idea that climate change
is
uh going to have a big impact on some of
these assets
i think so i mean you know i guess
there's this in different ways and one
the market essentially takes a consensus
view on how it thinks companies will do
in the future
and that's reflected in current market
prices now if enough people believe in
something then that will get reflected
in
in what the market thinks these
companies so if enough people are
concerned about climate risk
well and excited about climate-related
opportunities going forwards
then those views will ultimately get
reflected in how
investors in aggregate uh evaluate
companies right so that's kind of
and then maybe like one point about
tesla versus exxon earlier maybe that's
what we're starting to see i don't know
i mean it could be too early but
um i think
again i'm you know i share the hope of
others on the panel i i think
one one reason why the engagement by
investors on climate is i think become
starting to be incredibly successful is
that you're actually talking about
quite a small number of cars if you look
at the you know thousands of companies
in the global equity universe it could
be up to four well
depending on what universe so a global
development universe you're looking at
say 2 000 companies easily within that
at most 10 of those companies are kind
of like high carbon
companies so it's a it's a relatively
small number of companies and that
that's that's where uh investors
concerned about its agenda i think it's
starting to be
very successful because they've realized
it's a small number of companies you
know this risk is very very concentrated
in
say you know 200 ish plus companies
and that's that's a number you can work
with well globally at least and so
there's that that's why
i think pushing for extra commitments
among that
relatively small group of companies is
starting to be successful and
will continue to be so and that you know
that'll say well links back to what i
was saying about
market consensus and where what the
prospects of these companies are
i think companies do care about how they
look compared to their peers and
so perhaps the recent events um in the
excellent shareholder meeting again is a
further sign off that so
i i think yeah i think all these things
do do matter i think companies care
obviously large oil and gas companies
are still essentially taking fossil
fuels out of the ground which you know
in this context is problematic but
they're going to keep doing that for the
foreseeable future but
if they can at least commit to these
transition targets then that's
you know set us on the right path we
have about 90 seconds left so
kate i'm going to give you the last word
uh what about your experience speaking
to these businesses
um in the city do you think that we're
pushing our wishful
thinking on to them or are you quite
hopeful that this is actually a goal
that they have in mind
ah well i mean amazingly we've seen
commitments
uh uh in line with net zero by 2050 from
hsbc barclays aviva morgan stanley
santander uh lots of companies but not
enough as i said and i think uh the
important thing to think about is that
there's the economic argument as we've
said this is an area of growth
um and then there's simply being a good
ancestor being a good person thinking
about the future
and then in in all of this there's a
role for government now as they're
responsible for our society
for the economies and for the future we
leave uh the next generation so
there's no greater and more important
thing at the moment
for the government to do which is to
align our uk's financial sector with 1.5
degrees
well huge thanks to our panel for giving
us so much to go away and think about
um don't leave us just yet however you
can watch our next event on green
business practices how businesses can
achieve
net zero in 15 minutes time
uh but for now kate allen and benedict
thank you so much for joining me and a
big thanks again to wwf for sponsoring
this panel
see you later